all of you have stepped forward
to tell us
of how much you loved
daddy
i want to first apologize
for all of us as a family
because we have received so many
messages
on all kinds of media
and we haven't been able to respond to
all the prayers
and good wishes that we have received
so if you sent us a message and you
haven't heard from the person you sent
it to
it is not because we are ignoring or are
ungrateful for the message
we have just received so many
and we have just been overwhelmed
uddy would say
the love the world has shown
has warmed the cockles of our hearts
and he then would say
i don't know what a cockle is
but
whatever it is
it has been warmed
and since he was an english teacher and
if he didn't know what a cockle is i
definitely don't know what a cockle is
but our cockles
are
warm
we thank you
for loving
our father
grandfather husband
uncle
brother
brother-in-law
many of the messages we received have
said
thank you for sharing him with the world
well it actually is a two-way street
because we shared him with the world
you shared part of the love you held for
him
with us and so we
are thankful
and we are thankful
that all of you
have gathered in your many places
in person
or via
the wonders of technology
to be a part of celebrating daddy's life
throughout this week
and lastly
to him who has
gathered us here
we say
thank you
daddy
for the many ways you showed us love
for the many times
you challenged us
for the many times
you comforted us
[Music]
thank you